I spoke to parents and students here
that say today's atmosphere at school
was completely different many parents
learning from their kids about what
happened
it's been like a really rough start to
the year so far so students voicing
their thoughts about one of their own
passing away 16 year old student athlete
ashari Hughes died Thursday after
suffering a medical emergency during a
flag football game at Desert Oasis High
School according to principal Ian
Salzman staff immediately began
providing Medical Aid and continued
until paramedics arrived Desert Oasis
students who didn't know Hughes
personally share how they heard about
her passing and how their fellow
classmates are reacting the whole class
has started to like talk about it by
every single class I went to it was like
about the girl that passed away
and it's sad to hear I haven't met her
friends nor did I know her but I'm very
aware of that losing like a student
is very sad here usually it's like
louder but everyone was more quiet and
like it's kind of mellowed out and
everyone's Vibe which is kind of off we
were in gym and uh one of my friends we
were talking about it that's how I found
out and she said had mentioned that she
had sat next to her in one of her
classes while we await more information
on the incident and the cause of Hugh's
death many parents are just now finding
out from their kids about what happened
it's just unfortunate I just I just hope
that the the staff did everything they
could and that's all you can ask for an
accident like this on the field I think
has no reflection on what's what's going
on internally with the school
the coroner's office sharing with me
that Hughes was taken to Saint Rose
Hospital in Henderson where she later
died now there is a GoFundMe set up for
her as she is described as a passionate
loving and determined Girl Who Loved
football reporting near Desert Oasis
High School Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now